come pretende per essere mario bros
ma non me l'hanno permesso dice che
siete troppo persone per bene quindi
giustamente dice non possiamo scherzare
sono stato contaminato anche io in modo
positivo e vorrei contaminare anche voi
se vi aspettate una poetica non la so
fare
non ne sono capace se invece vi
aspettate una parabola quella si faceva
duemila anni fa e la faceva il mio capo
sono qui invece per raccontarvi una
storia la mia storia una storia
particolare
una storia diciamo che ha fatto sì che
il futuro diventasse un gioco da ragazzi
e vorrei che questa contaminazione
positiva in me avvenisse anche in
ciascuno di voi
nel senso che sono convinto che il
futuro sarà un gioco da ragazzi
se tutti insieme possiamo giocare in
questo campo che la nostra nazione la
nostra terra e fare in modo che il
nostro joystick sia il luogo dove
potersi incontrare dove cioè poter
portare contaminazioni positive ma tutto
questo però poteva nascere soltanto da
un pazzo un pazzo come me che mi ritengo
un prete ribelle non sto ai canoni come
don antonio ha detto prima assolutamente
credo invece che c'è bisogno di un
qualcosa in più per poter parlare al
mondo con il mondo ma in modo
particolare per il mondo e quindi tutto
inizia da un incontro speciale
particolare ma anche casuale a cinecittà
era il 2002 quando un amico una persona
che incontra casualmente e nulla
viene per caso credetemi nulla invece va
a parlarmi dei bambini
io ero entrato a cinecittà cercando di
convertire qualcuno ma mi hanno
convertito loro a me a un certo punto
sono entrato nel mondo del cinema e poi
dal mondo del cinema da questo incontro
entro in un altro mondo che è quello dei
videogiochi e dei cartoni animati ossia
poter scoprire la gioia dei bambini
attraverso un sorriso mi sembravano cose
strane per me in quel momento sembravano
soprattutto situazioni assurde ma io
quello che mi viene detto lo metto un
poco da parte e che cosa faccio inizio a
pensare inizio cioè a cambiare il mio
modo di vedere il mio modo di pensare
nei confronti dei bambini nel senso che
vorrei entrare in quel mondo partendo
dal basso e che cosa facendo creando
soprattutto un festival in modo che
ciascuno potesse divertirsi ma
riflettere ed a quel festival che nasce
nel 2009 chiamato playmont festival
internazionale di cartoni animati dei
videogiochi
nasce tutto questo che dopo dopo tanti
anni viene fuori una grande realtà
tutto nasce da questo festival numerose
furono le agenzie di stampa che
iniziarono a venire rai gulp e rai yoyo
iniziarono a entrare in questo mondo
volevano sapere di questo prete qualcuno
mi disse non ricordo noferi uno dei
direttori del di rai gulp disse ma tu
sei un pazzo scatenato non si può fare
tutto questo perché non si può fare se
bisogna dare una risposta dai dei
bambini i quali non sanno che cosa c'è
dietro un cartone animato e dietro un
videogioco che cosa c'è dietro a un
cartone animato una filiera e io in quel
festival facevo vedere ai ragazzi come
nasceva un cartone animato e come
nasceva un videogioco attraverso
professionisti del settore niente di
strano niente di particolare niente di
eccezionale nella semplicità ma
soprattutto tenendo conto di un'idea che
mi fu data qualche anno prima
ossia dare un sorriso ai bambini
attraverso i cartoni animati e
videogiochi e iniziamo con questo
festival
ma da questo festival nasce poi una
grande idea che la passione poteva
diventare formazione e la formazione
poteva diventare posto di lavoro perché
il mondo del videogioco e il mondo dei
cartoni animati aveva bisogno di persone
che creavano dal niente idee e mettevano
su cartoni animati e videogiochi
allora qualcuno mi disse non lo
dimenticherò mai il guro del kart del
videogioco italiano riccardo cangini di
sé con me perché non metti su un corso e
fare in modo che noi possiamo avere noi
società che facciamo videogiochi non
possiamo avere dei professionisti del
settore e fare in modo che i nostri
ragazzi i nostri figli i nostri giovani
posso entrare possono entrare nel mondo
del lavoro dalla porta principale
accetto la sfida lascio un attimo da
parte però tutto questo tutto quello che
mi stava accadendo intorno
accetto la sfida nel frattempo che cosa
faccio però iniziò a pensare io sono un
ragazzo del sud un prete del sud che
vive però che sta vivendo la sua
esperienza a roma in un mondo tutto
particolare il mondo vicine città e
quindi portare a giu questo festival è
portare giù una realtà sembrava un
miraggio
un'impresa impossibile ma soprattutto in
una realtà del sud e di provincia
resetto la mia esistenza
metto a nudo tutto faccio un lavaggio al
mio cervello
e dico andare in spagna nel momento in
cui vado in spagna ad un incontro di
videogiochi mi rendo conto che da
quell'incontro poteva nascere la grande
idea di quel 2002 venuta fuori a
cinecittà ossia si fa più concreta
l'idea di una realtà accademica è
incentrata soprattutto sui videogiochi e
sui cartoni animati meglio ancora
l'animazione perché ero convinto di dare
la giusta dimensione accademica a dei
ragazzi che erano entrati in questo
mondo chi disegnava grafica 3d ti poteva
fare programmazione chi poteva fare il
game designer che poteva avere tanti
strumenti per poter entrare nel mondo
del lavoro ma non veniva mai chiamato
dottore dottore in arti digitali
qualcuno dice ma tu sei pazzo non puoi
andare avanti a pensare queste cose
i miei primi nemici erano la chiesa
guerra dappertutto
io che sono un prete ribelle a calci ma
senza pensarci due volte perché ho
sempre sostenuto che se vogliamo essere
per la gente e con la gente dobbiamo
essere nei problemi della gente non
stare lontano non stare sul pulpito a
predicare se poi nella vita concreta
non diamo una mano a chi ne ha bisogno e
tutto questo
[Applauso]
e tutto questo
inizia nascere nel 2012
ma che cosa avviene sapendo che il
videogioco è un'arte e quindi non va
demonizzata la chiesa si mette lì e dice
che danno fastidio ai videogiochi
possono essere demoniaci
no invece in me ha svegliato il mio
diavolo che cm come dice zucchero e ho
sfidato tutti a far capire che il
videogioco non è da demonizzare perché
il videogioco può essere un elemento
essenziale per fare comunità
per restare insieme mio nipote ha
imparato l'inglese giocando lo possiamo
demonizzare no assolutamente
però noi come chiesa poiché siamo fatemi
passare la parola ci crediamo
i puri davanti ma dietro abbiamo degli
scheletri che fanno paura che possa
succedere che cosa succede che io dico
no non vanno demonizzati anzi è lo
strumento essenziale perchè ci può
essere una crescita sia intellettuale
sia professionale e perché no familiare
allora a quel punto che cosa faccio mi
rendo conto che in italia era difficile
poter entrare nel mondo dell'università
per la porta principale metto su il
piano di studio e dico no ok
un amico mi chiama e mi dice vieni a
malta perché probabilmente amata accetta
questo tuo progetto accetta questa tua
idea vado amata incontro questa persona
evaristo bartolo ministro della cultura
maltese mio siamo diventati grandi amici
tra poco diventerà il presidente della
repubblica maltese e lo ringrazio
affettuosamente lui percepisce da subito
l'idea mi mette in contatto iniziano le
pratiche inizia soprattutto il modo per
cercare lui fa in modo
tutto avvenga in modo molto veloce
perché mi riconoscessero il titolo il
primo corso a livello europeo di arti
digitali animazione e video gioco
succede il finimondo
tanto che succede il finimondo che
panorama mi rincorre e mi dice ma
possibile che non possiamo più parlare
con te no può dire parlare vede che loro
ti mandiamo giù un amico che si chiama
marco morello che vuole farti
assolutamente un'intervista
ok va bene scende giù lui mi chiama e mi
dice e mi è rimasto questa etichetta
parlo con padre joystick attenzione il
joystick non l'ho mai usato non so non
sapevo nemmeno che cos'era l'avevo visto
giocare con i miei nipoti ma non sapevo
che cosa era il videogioco o meglio quel
quell'aggeggio quello strumento che i
bambini usano in modo molto concreto
poco fa qualcuno mi diceva ma secondo
lei come un prete serene se dovesse dare
un consiglio un prete che cosa reti del
semplice non sai giocare
mettiti accanto a un bambino imparerai a
giocare anche tu sicuramente e farai più
effetto nel cuore del bambino
eze domani tu lo chiami a chi dici viene
ammessa come perché andiamo a giocare
insieme
hai preso il bambino lai conquistato
questo è il modo per poter entrare nel
cuore del bambino
lui viene mi fa l'intervista diventa
diventa questo padre joystick inizia la
rai de la vita in diretta di tutto di
più
intanto mettiamo su questo questo corso
di laurea nel 2017 2018 si laureano i
primi 40 ragazzi dico prima 40 laureati
l'ottanta per cento
e scusate se è poco l'ottanta per cento
cioè 32 ragazzi hanno trovato un posto
di lavoro
[Applauso]
il mio rammarico però chi sia questo
posto di lavoro
l'hanno trovata all'estero bruttissimo
cioè io che sono italiano
devo andare all'estero per trovare una
mia sistemazione è brutto e qualche
giorno fa un ragazzo mi ha chiamato e mi
ha detto donna fammi tornare nella mia
terra è forte questo
[Applauso]
però i sogni non finiscono qui
il mio sogno è fare il catechismo della
chiesa cattolica a videogiochi
[Applauso]
e con chi anche con i miei ragazzi e
sono convinto che se hai milioni non
dico la cifra che hanno speso per il
video catechismo che hanno fatto un un
bordello che non finisce mai
io non lo vedrò mai perché non mi metto
davanti alla televisione a rompermi come
diceva l'onda don antonio le palle a
guardarmi questo colossal no tu vuoi
parlare ai bambini
vuoi fare in modo che i tuoi ragazzi
vengono in chiesa devi parlare il loro
stesso linguaggio
oggi che cosa dicono i bambini oi
ragazzi giocando a fort night
immaginate un po che io creo un
videogioco in cui vado a dire o scappato
gesù cristo
ma ho sfidato gesù cristo cioè ho
ammazzato oggi su gesù cristo ma ho
usato il termine che usano i miei
ragazzi che usano i ragazzi è il modo
migliore per far rientrare in chiesa
perché uso il loro stesso linguaggio non
c'è più motivo di parlare con i ragazzi
ma bisogna parlare per i ragazzi quindi
scioccato che cosa ha fatto chi l'ha
fatto chi ha sciupato il sommo sacerdote
perché ho detto abb dice il bambino te
lo dico io perché per chi ha venduto ha
comprato per trenta denari di giuda ha
venduto cristo e lui quindi ha sciupato
cioè ha comprato questo sono le parole
che noi dobbiamo far imparare ai nostri
bambini per portarli in chiesa
immaginatevi il bambino che viene in
chiesa con il telefonino viene al
catechismo o andiamo a giocare c'è la
catechista che ci fa giocare quindi
dobbiamo fare anche la cultura verso i
catechisti
mi auguro che non ci siano qua se non mi
ammazzano cioè dobbiamo fare imparare da
loro come si gioca sul telefonino ma
questa è la cultura che noi possiamo
dare ai nostri bambini cioè il
catechismo della chiesa cattolica in un
videogioco sarà quello sarà un kolossal
sicuramente ci stiamo già pensando ma
abbiamo già scritto la storia stiamo
facendo lo storyboard e fanno molto lo
vedremo io non compro il video
catechismo a 11 euro ma sicuramente
potrò regalare ai bambini del catechismo
di tutto il mondo il videogioco della
chiesa cattolica il catechismo della
chiesa cattolica in videogiochi e poi
c'è un altro sogno quello di entrare
nelle carceri minorili e dare un futuro
a questi ragazzi
loro hanno commesso degli errori ma non
vanno demonizzati vanno aiutati a
immettersi di nuovo nella società è il
modo migliore per poterli aiutare
credo che sia proprio il videogioco è un
altro sogno che spero si realizzi che
questa terra non si possa chiamare più
molla taranto giusto
molle taranto giusto ma soltanto taranto
perché io tra non molto e spero che mi
aprono le porte fino adesso me l'hanno
chiusa ma io sono uno tosto verrò a
mettere l'università dell'animazione e
del videogioco anche in questa terra
grazie al joystick e adesso nervi saldi
fermi
occhio perché la prossima il prossimo
spicci e davvero particolare quando si
fa